good morning gamers it's night actually
Connor is in my house get the food I
have no choice he's made himself at home
he just won't leave Connor
one day hey one day you'll learn I also
had this old man living in my house now
I don't know why but he sells me glow
sticks I think it seemed to rave parties
works when went just like my glow stick
am I right gamers I'm so sorry I got a
bug net from him so now we can catch
stuff we can also buy a blonde hair cut
from him shuriken sickle hey there's a
squirrel right now let's catch it come
here got him and now will them free hey
I got you a friend alright so I've also
been building IKEA Tower
oh my god yes glorious IKEA Tower hmm
yes and there you have legitimate stock
gorgeous
I know you're all in very impressed but
also I'm when trying to dig straight
down goddamn this takes forever what's
that hey Alfred what did you do to the
squirrel oh my god embarrassing also for
those of you are worried cactus chairs
still there
I have not defeated any bosses I have
not done anything okay we can't go down
there it is look at this so far down Oh
God
I'm stuck in cobweb Oh God Oh God I'm
fine it's a trap that's a trap isn't it
I've watched tutorials I think that's a
pressure plate so if I step all night I
will die bottom you slice darts trap
more like fart trap em alright gamers
nice yeah I know
nice no one's gonna die on my watch why
the music gets so funky Jesus oh shoot I
need to build I gotta go up again dammit
[Music]
Connor get out of my house
you don't live here okay I need to make
wooden walls ok let's let's capture this
bunny hey bunny mine you can change the
room
Connor can live here what I can change
where he lives
yeah that's right Connor you live here
old man lives here ok so I can also make
I think AB oh yes just a wooden one but
it's still it's something and then I can
make purple torch what flaming arrows
cool make a couple of this so now if I
want to kill someone
Jesus I can pick them up again hold up I
got to stay on track here we were
heading down and down we go downward
spiral we're gonna dig straight to help
gamers okay we're back to funky music
land I like it is that diamonds I knew
it I knew we could do it gamers I'm so
proud how is leave some funky Kong music
man Jesus our quest to dig to hell
continues I think something bad is that
underneath here oh my god what is that
what whoa whoa hold up how do I kill
this yeah it's not a freaking shuriken
my shuriken okay
epic I gotta show you again brah I've
been waiting for the shuriken murder
will committed brah I'm literally Neruda
in this game okay okay we got to be
careful I don't know what waits I never
been here I don't know what this is it's
red slime dangerous each shuriken
hey we got platinum baby I'm the Joker
baby I'm just gonna the symmetry and
just dig down just waterboard it can't
hurt me right I can't you can can it
alright I'm thinking straight down I
don't care hey what is going on okay I
don't know how I did they
oh god I'm Johnny
can I use torch hissing water now we got
to redirect the water right oh you can
use glow sticks okay don't call me a
sink your brain death oh I got a glow
stick let's go yeah what the hell is
cool that was awesome
oh god am i draining that from your glow
sticks stop throwing them how do I
please stop throwing them I swear to God
well they just stay there this game
makes no sense is it worth going down
here and what am i doing I don't even
know is that a [ __ ] fish get the [ __ ]
out of my face other shorts in Terraria
I need to know am i making more water
I'm just gonna dig straight down at this
point I haven't shown Marcia the puffer
fish eating name I would never do it
that's bad news for everyone that's our
wars begin can I create an air pocket
maybe I can't all right well well well
cool that's some big range in it and you
know it throw a girl a glow stick in
there nice only problem is I'm still
with the water there it is yeah go away
water stinky water how long does it take
to get to hell how long would that take
me realistically it's like a nether
realm in Terraria like minecraft er she
says why does this look so ominous whoa
nice
Oh No Oh No drown town okay god it's
really dark here cold we're safe from
water now keep digging
press control all right sorry no why is
this happening
stop it water I keep thinking I find
something and then it just there's
nothing
Jesus Christ let's scare me what is that
okay he's quite tall isn't it let's make
a let's make a little opening party
suck my bow Frankenstein keep pushing
that's right oh yeah eat it
am i dying I'm dying not on my watch
coward what the [ __ ] is that
back off okay push see easy oh that's a
big ass line I don't know how I feel
about that oh it's a mother slime mother
slam no you need to go piece of [ __ ] are
you kidding me I lost 23 silver down
there
don't say a freaking word Connor don't
you say a freaking word to me Oh God
how do i how do I get through that I
don't think of that Oh No
Shane knife is that good okay there's a
lot of them in there there it is whoa
whoa what get his toast get his toast
yeah I get his toast shame knife awesome
I get older toast then toast yes I gotta
say like one of the main things with
Minecraft is that it's kind of a bummer
how you can't really dig down that much
like once you beat minecraft mining it
becomes kind of obsolete almost should I
be afraid here oh nice whoa is that
freaking gold dude told pass the Frick
is topaz topaz more like no pass cuz I
don't want him Connor get out of my
house you don't live here don't you ever
go in there cactus chair all right I
should have a lot of stuff now oh my god
it's a cute squirrel that's adorable bro
I can make so much stuff I'm freaking
out how do I pick
zombi banner oh god I didn't close the
door tonight
[Music]
oops sorry
oops more mana okay yeah they're beating
to the music yeah not gonna lie that
zombies this vibrant right now my gut is
telling me I should get the staff and I
did it so now let's try it oh my god oh
let's try it on the bunny Wow I can make
a freakin toilet but I'm making toilets
I'm making freakin bathroom like making
lead door maybe I should do that on the
front doors I'm out of lead shame Jesus
Christ it's okay yeah that's more cool
I can make traps all right who wants the
toilet yes all right poopy here put me
where we'll be here nice can I use it
what's good to sell
[Music]
to befriend this is really good - should
I buy the helmet for gold dude I'm not
that rich topes is worth a lot okay now
I have four gold now can buy the mining
helmet okay
run my hair be yellow initially epic
okay time to explore the world
I am so strong now bro I got a godly
staff come on bring it you cowards got
nothing he has some so strong
oh yes the desert where the desert trees
resides I can't shop them I just eat a
mushroom I didn't mean to do that
look at this coward eat eat eat eat
thank you nothing can kill me what is
this Tintin
whoa game just changed like that
okay death death and suffering have we
got mushrooms in your Vikings used to
eat mushrooms well fun little trivia for
you guys oh god what happened down here
alright some quick loot I'll take it I
really need to start using my rope where
is it
increase the mining speed by 25% what I
didn't know I had that oh you you
Connor you did this where's a health
friend
god dammit I'm angry unbelievable
I'll kill everything that comes in my
way now no more mr. nice pie get it why
is there nothing in this game we got a
schist what climbing claws allows
abilities to slide down where do I put
the climbing clothes yeah well what is
this
oh god slime I hate you I hate what is
golden chest okay alright okay magic
mirror gazing it to return home our
journey continues downwards I'm a little
scared what the [ __ ] is that you piece
of garbage suffering pain what is this
life crystal I got like - dude this is
fine it was the sand
I don't like sand it gets everyone now
today's sand heal brah I'm not afraid
more golden chests dude
dude there's a chandelier brah hello hey
hey you know what I want to do I want to
change so I use this cuz the sword is
not that good what how does boomerang
work how much you're damaged insane bro
there's pianos dude I got a mine mine
all mine
yes suck it Oh God pain die oh yeah and
I got the bear claws to look at me we
should probably use the rope over the
action the life crystal gives more
health oh wow thanks why did this game
become so much more exciting out of
nowhere what happened
No done okay boomerang it's not a good
look at my paws dude what is that
then suffering and pain what it became
tiny slimes
oh god what is that platinum yeah well
my mage is walking around in water flick
per potion does that mean I can drink in
water drinking water yeah that's that's
what I meant
let's see swiftly moves swiftly in
liquids okay that's basically what it
said hmm I think we're done here
eh was uh well there's people in my Oh
hot babe in my house what's his name
again
Connor you better stay away from her
what's up girl no I bet she was
impressed that I did that I bet she was
impressed all right Katie what's up have
you seen an old man in the dungeon he
looks trouble I can't do anything more
with that plastic surgery excuse me what
oh that's so mean
so she can heal me okay what the hell
that's so rude
can't do any more what the hell Alfred
would never talk to me like this dude
we're making great progress piano piano
smanos replace a piano here wait Connor
wait I forgot well have all this awesome
decoration man whoa you're not gonna
have that fancy want I'm gonna have the
fancy one yes whoa
Platinum I can make platinum stuff
Sergei what can I make are merging hey
still needs a torch ready to head back
hello this time we're gonna make some
changes
oh my god it took forever now oh Jesus
Christ what is that what was that whoa
ha ha I look like a naked ape every time
I look at my wooden arm
tell me I'm wrong if I'm dying can I
just activate the mirror to like link
all if yes epic you know what I want to
do ultimate mining how do I use it
okay I should be faster at mining now oh
my god
look at the speed look at the speed oh
my God look at this video okay and then
we can use the sleeper potion yes
whoa Jesus Christ
flipper wasn't joking huh Oh God okay
seriously damn these are strong stand
still and die whoa damn maybe I can make
an air pocket here no they're rare the
piggies are rare awesome air precious
air oh god no all right you guys told me
I should get the gold back where all my
gold then you can lie to me 15 gold damn
I'm rich brah come at me then
Arius done you're done Oh God we're
gonna get this water out
don't worry gamers air pocket they were
built in China
Bob the Builder mod don't ever dis my
haircut ever
what they're smart they're what they're
smart they're by water it's still going
down
what's hurting me what's hurting me I
don't see then what you can build stairs
what why did no one tell me I'm in
playing for hours I hate you guys oh
crap
oh wow oh wow what is that Oh God
oh god that's Oh God Lucy Lucy not me
not me now I'm not [ __ ] you are jeepers
creepers
what is that oh we found someone hello
hey hey thanks hon now I can finally do
my hair bro she sells milk no it's hair
dye this is gonna ask where she got that
milk from bit/s I'll buy some hair dye
what were you doing down here
explain yourself woman oh god it's over
it's over
oh god it's over what's over yeah what
was that
arrows webslinger
what is that equippable where how do I
use it I got an achievement how do I use
it
II whoa dude whoa girl do you see this
what so now I don't even have to worry
about anything I can just grab a look at
it my way whoa suck my ass gasps so this
is a spider biome or what are we talking
here
that takes a long time to shop she'll
tell me to stop if it's diamonds I don't
want to break it I can't shop big I
can't shop big what is that need a
better pickaxe oh god I made a mistake
letting this water in didn't have night
yeah that'll do god this place is scary
oh hey lingonberry I can make a bed with
cobweb
that's disgusting Oh God
that's what I thought
oh god there's a lot of them there's a
lot of them yeah why do they sound so we
don't think so spider okay this looks
like a new place whoa whoa what is this
suffer because you're ugly
mine mine allows the holder to double
jump so I can double jump down what
that's so cool
come on let me through this passage is
making me anxious can I not carry it am
i full full there should be a sign that
I should return home but I don't wanna
yeah maybe I should go back and make a
better pickaxe okay go back brah I'm
getting good sup gamers Bryce he's
sitting on the [ __ ] toilet
alright let's not disturb anything
I got bombs to extend helmet hmm
I kind of already have a helmet that's
all oh so what do I have to stand
pickaxe that's the best I can do
why am I so garbage pink gel Ruby now I
can make a platinum pickaxe nice let's
do that done pass Connor about crafting
okay hey Connor I don't really want to
talk to you but place material here
[Music]
what sand gun illegal gun parts what 30
ranged damage how do I make it then
yellow fades Blaine Connor why have you
been not telling me Tim's didn't watch
Kingston Greaves how much do I need to
make it oh it says 25 whoa so much
Connor you piece of [ __ ] I hate you I
can make it Mahoney chips there's so
much tub Jesus Lord oh my god I can make
a cocktail how to make a robe okay
better armor
that's it apparently okay that's clearly
a lot more to the game that I have not
yet to understand it actually makes
sense to have Connor living on this
floor then this room is missing a wall
that's because of this you're not living
here oh my god that's kind of cool it
will actually become like a hotel for
people okay you live here all right
Hotel like yeah that's the name of the
place yeah area mine all day mine all
night great place to use your bombs tent
what I almost let all that water out but
yet yeah I think I have a fall damage
potion at least I saw it somewhere
damn it could be good to him and this
mining helmet kicks ass dude you can
double jump toward folders okay nice so
that's a really good one to find them
bro we're shopping this place we keep
going gamers yes yes yeah well with the
trap again are you kidding me and my
poison yeah oh it's so cute and now it's
dead okay what do we have here well well
well
bro I mind so freaking fast what is this
why is there painting of me what the
hell whoa someone's I have Cthulhu
I got boots of Hermes the wearer can run
super fast do it I want that painting on
me nice whoa it's like a mushroom
whoa whoa hold up I'm not that fast
though okay when you accelerate you
getting speed okay another her maze
foots this is super fun I'm super into
this game at this point there's so much
to explore don't summon Cthulhu I think
I'm scared I'm like 5% into the game are
you kidding me yeah I found someone new
arrived uh-huh come on all right deeper
we go gamers whoa we're in a mineshaft
now whoa whoa careful
that's definitely lava back to Hell
where you belong coward what what is
this I can't mind this either nice okay
so apparently I press R whoa
bye oh I can jump with it it's so cool
die okay he died too this is so sick Oh
God
brake brake brake brake brake brake up
hold up hold up hold up
whoa the speed on this unit I'm full
No if i teleport back home I have to so
go hoedown so far by the dynamite yeah
yeah yeah let's do that
oh my god there's more here a mine all
day I'm mine all night yeah okay let's
throw away my [ __ ] I don't need whoopee
cushion are you serious this games
taking the piss all right dynamite time
boom boom boom baby yeah oh god I made
lava everywhere okay let's not go where
do I go then here
it's how we do it in Sweden [ __ ] oh oh
oh no oh no no no no no no no mistakes
were made
oh oh oh
into the lava into the lava oh wow oh
this is bad this is a real bad mmm damn
it no I wasn't looking
I was looking at the shed the shed your
fault
bro there's a Fisher guy in my house now
Norrish him how do I use the whoopee
cushion good game this is a good game
definitely saving that way I definitely
need to place this I think I can make
some better armor now this is five
defense why do I keep drinking that it's
so cozy now then we came so far I love
it
I can change my hairstyle why would I
ever do that look how beautiful - all
right next time I'll summon the eye of
Cthulhu I'm ready I feel like I'm 100%
ready super game super fun game with
what I try to say I wanna play boy
alright guys hope you guys enjoy this
episode if you did smash like subscribe
and let me know if you want more
terraria and that's it for me for now
hey though hey we're all excited about
the new game that's coming out and I
can't wait to play it it starts with the
letter P can you guess what it is
here the pie pick ceiling of course what
you thought it was Pokemon dumbass you
stinky brainer
you